[Music]
most mornings at 4:45 a.m. the alarm
goes off beside my bed the coffee goes
off about the same time on a timer I'll
need it about then Sharon and I get up
and spend a little time talking and
drinking coffee and praying and catching
up on our Bible and scanning through
what's happening in the news and I
always jump jump on TweetDeck and just
see what's happening out there in the
world on Twitter and I always find some
interesting stuff about you know what
5:30 6:00 in the morning or something
like that and this morning is no
exception
now here's my rule about Twitter okay I
will not come after you personally on
Twitter unless you call me out and then
I might respond if you call me out and
so I am I do not feel like I am
prohibited from responding when you
trash me
I'm not prohibited from responding now
there are people that say oh just ignore
everybody don't be thin-skinned well I'm
not thin-skinned but I just think it's
always interesting that you're allowed
to say whatever the flip you want to say
and I'm gonna loud to say anything back
so I just always just let want to let
you know rules for Dave Ramsey Twitter
is this if you use my name anywhere in
the social media universe I might see it
and I might respond I might likely have
fun with you and make fun of you that's
possible or I could use you as an object
lesson which is what I'm gonna do today
so apparently there's an article
floating around which I hadn't seen
until this morning and I did look it up
about jay-z the rapper jay-z he had one
expensive night out in Manhattan on
Sunday according to this article on Fox
and he was dropping more than a hundred
and ten thousand dollars to celebrate
the birthday of one Perez's close friend
and the president of rock Nation sports
Jay skipped the all-star game and took
one and a group of rock nation execs to
Zuma in Midtown for dinner which is a
nice place picking up the tab there for
13 grand then the group headed down to
made in Mexico and in would spending
nine thousand dollars on drinks
including jay-z's
cognac his a cognac brand followed by a
stop at a nearby nightclub playroom
where even though they were at by this
point down to a group of six they
ordered and paid full price for forty
bottles of Ace of Spades champagne which
is really nice champagne also owned by
jay-z the stunned playroom server posted
J's check on snapchat which came to a
whopping ninety one thousand one hundred
and thirty five dollars that was his bar
tab ninety one thousand one hundred
thirty five dollars and included an epic
eleven thousand dollar tip well played
jay-z and now I tell you I'm a child of
the 70s and so I'm more like Boston
journey heart Eagles so rap wasn't even
invented back when I was cool by the
time rap came around I wasn't cool and
so I've never really developed a taste
for it but I have been so intrigued by
the rappers even though it's not my I
don't listen to rap music I'm not
against it I'm not mad at it's just not
my style
and yet I've gotten to meet several of
them and hang out and they they are an
interesting crew we got one that does
some stuff on money that comes on the
air here with me it's a great guy
jay-z if my all accounts is one of the
world's best businessmen he makes a lot
of money he does a great job managing
his business and you know he's got a
line of his guys online of champagne
he's got his own line of cognac he's got
his own line of this his own line of
that and so not only is he made a
bazillion dollars as a music artist and
is a world-class legitimate music artist
obviously buddies he's a crate business
guy apparently I've never met him I
don't know him but I mean I've just
known this you know one degree two
degrees of separation for years about
jay-z and I don't know anything about
his character I don't know the guy at
all but he makes a lot of money he does
he manages his business affairs very
well by all appearances and so I just
looked it up I thought you drop you drop
a hundred grand ninety one grand plus an
11 grand tip in a nightclub you drop a
hundred
I wonder what you make because people
always go WOW that I just that's
unbelievable well apparently he made
forty-two million dollars in 2017 and he
dropped a hundred grand last night or
night before last or whatever it was
which I it's hard for I mean I grew up
in Antioch Tennessee to get my head
around dropping 100 grand on a bar tab I
can't get my brain wrapped around that
emotionally i but it always helps me and
there for you to do ratios on things and
so I just start taking zeros off so what
if you were a doctor and you made or
whatever an Indian chief I don't know
what you are and you make a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars a year I'm sorry
four hundred and twenty thousand dollars
here
he makes forty-two million let's say you
made four hundred and twenty thousand
dollars a year him dropping a hundred
grand on a night on the town would be at
making forty-two million would be like
someone making four hundred and twenty
thousand dollars a year spending a
hundred dollars if you make forty-two
thousand dollars a year it would be like
you spending ten dollars in other words
he's okay it's weird for you and me
because our incomes are not forty two
million dollars a year I've got a very
nice income it's my 42 million a year
and so it's weird to look at somebody
spend 100 grand well you could feed
starving children well who says he
doesn't say feed starving children shot
up we don't know what he does or doesn't
do but this got this idea that you have
to hate on jay-z
for dropping 100 grand when the guy's a
world-class business guy world-class
artist at what he does
again I'm not defending him because he's
a friend of mine I don't even know him
but I'm just defending the concept a
he's earned the right B he didn't hurt
anybody
see he really didn't spend that much cuz
he bought his own stuff so by the time
he goes back through wholesale and and
back into his account he's gonna make
money I mean he he paid for
at the restaurant he didn't mess around
with him there but but I mean it is his
stuff that got sold to the restaurant
hello the champagne and the cognac that
is his line so I'm sure I mean I don't
know whether it's licensing deal or
whether he actually owns those
businesses but you know and there was it
wasn't a net of a hundred but even if it
wasn't a net of a hunter grant even if
he wasn't buying his own stuff if you
make forty two million dollars a year
and you spend a hundred thousand dollars
on a night on the town that's like
someone making four hundred and twenty
thousand dollars spending a hundred
dollars or someone's making forty two
thousand spending ten dollars now when
we come back from the break here's what
we're going to address in the next
segment guy tweets I'm up to my elbows
in every day making a third of this in a
year or was it makes thirty thousand
dollars a year and I'm the lazy self
entitled millennial for wanting to make
more money I clearly have a different
definition of lazy self entitled than
the sean hannity and dave ramsey crowd
and he prints out a picture of jay-z's
spending the picture of the ticket that
was out there for ninety one thousand
dollars plus an eleven thousand dollar
tip not a bad tip not twenty percent but
not a bad tip so let's address this when
we come back it's something to talk
about because you called me out dude so
we're gonna talk about this because it's
an interesting lesson for you to learn
this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]
okay so I ended up getting in the middle
of this because some guy calls me out on
Twitter so JC has an adjacent rapper and
businessman makes forty two million a
year has a great night on the town
buying Ace of Spades champagne which is
his own champagne at a club runs up a
ninety one thousand dollar tab puts an
eleven thousand dollar tip on it drops a
hundred grand in one night he makes
forty two million a year last year
awesome good for him I'm proud for him
and by the way hands out he's seen
handing out bottles to other tables in
the club according to the article as
well and if you don't know Ace of Spades
champagnes about three hundred bucks a
bottle okay
it's like Dom Perignon okay I mean it's
pretty serious I don't know if it says
good necessarily I'm not champagne
connoisseur but it's about the same
price point in other words and so that's
like someone making four hundred twenty
thousand dollars a year spending a
hundred bucks in one night it's like
someone making $42,000 a year spending
ten dollars in one night well that's
opulent that's gaudy that is over the
top that's extravagant you shouldn't do
that
says you see there's the problem we have
an America you get to figure out what
jay-z does with his money didn't do
anything wrong he was celebrating his
friend being generous to other tables
promoting his own brand of his product
in do anything wrong is it does it blow
my mind that you can drop a hundred
grand yeah I can't I admit it
emotionally blows my mind but then a guy
comes on Twitter and says I'm up to my
elbows in bleep every day making a third
of this in a year thirty thousand I
guess and I'm the lazy self entitled
millennial for wanting to make more
money I clearly have a very different
definition of lazy self entitled than
the Sean Hannity Dave Ramsey crowd and I
can't speak for the Sean Hannity crowd I
don't know except for the extent they
overlap with my crowd but I will tell
you two things number one I take offense
to the idea that I somehow don't like
Millennials because I have defended
Millennials many times here on the air I
have said I have a ton of them working
for me here and the ones that work for
me are awesome now there are two types
of millennial sucks and awesome there's
no middle ground
we love Millennials that are missional
and driven
and man that there they'll fight their
fight to win I love them I got a bunch
of them on my team my children are
Millennials so I'm not anti millennial
millennial is an age group it's not a
mindset is there a percentage of them
that are participation trophy living in
their mother's basement of whiners yeah
yeah there is this guys apparently one
of them and so I mean that's the deal
right so why are you griping if you make
$30,000 a year about jay-z's success ha
now that's what I wanted to talk about
right there because see there's an end
let me just tell you there's a couple
things in your character that pre Dupree
depose you to being successful that's
said that wrong but anyway predispose
you to being successful that's the
correct word for a proper word okay one
of one of the things that predisposes
you to being successful is gratitude
grateful people are highly attractive
whether you're a millennial or you're a
baby boomer or whatever you are
bitterness envy jealousy predispose you
to continue to be a failure in life and
so if you want to throw stones through
other people's window because you don't
have what they have
I will tell you that predisposes you to
not win the chances of you winning go
down when you do that very few people
sit in whine and gripe about other
people's success and on their way to
becoming successful
it's very rare the people that become
successful almost always are people who
celebrate other people success and so
number one I'm not against Millennials
I'm for Millennials and I don't think
they're lazy self-entitled all of them
but I think some of them are and some
baby boomers are lazy and self-entitled
and some Xers and gin wires and
where else are lazy and self-entitled
lazy in self-entitled is a thing it's
not an age and I'm wanting to make my
make a third of this and I'm wanting to
make more money no you're not wanting to
make more money what you're saying in
your tweet is you want somebody give you
more money because you breathe air
that's lazy in self-entitled if you want
to make more than jay-z don't do more
than jay-z if you want to make more than
$30,000 a year go do more than people
that make $30,000 a year I've made
$30,000 a year I've made less one year I
made 6,000 bucks
god it's a long year it's awful listen
let me just tell you if you won't make
more money you can make more money but
griping about jay-z's bar tab and
indicating that you don't make enough
because he has a bar tab that makes us
three times what you make in a year is
not an indication of a societal problem
it's an indication that you are jealous
worse than that you're envious jealousy
is I want what you have
envious is I don't want you to have what
you have because I don't think I can get
it well I'll never have a car like that
so you shouldn't be allowed to I'm not
going to get an inheritance so you
shouldn't be allowed to I'm not able to
blank blank blank so you shouldn't be
allowed to that's envious envy is an
evil spirit that is loose in the land of
America today envy and jealousy is an
evil spirit and it has invaded some of
you of all age groups well the one
percenters the evil one percenters the
evil the evil millionaires the evil fat
cats on Wall Street the evil this and
you assume automatically that someone
that has more than you has done
something wrong to get there and should
have it taken away from them the
envy be careful with envy because let me
give you a ratio if you make a household
income of $34,000 a year up to your
elbows in bleep every day you're in the
top 1% of income earners in the world so
someone in a different country could
look over here in a different setting
that makes a lot less than you and say
oh I don't you know I don't make that in
10 years and you make that because
you're in the United States and you make
$34,000 a year and you shouldn't have
that because I don't think I ever will
that is a dangerous thing if you catch
yourself being jealous or even worse
envious of someone else's success that
is setting you up to remain not only
bitter but in failure celebrate other
people's success celebrate other
people's success defend their right to
go and be successful there are people in
this world that are better looking than
Dave Ramsey isn't matter fact there's a
lot of them there are people in this
world that are a lot more talented than
Dave Ramsey as a matter of fact there's
a lot of them there are people in this
world that are smarter than Dave Ramsey
as a matter of fact there's a lot of
them there's a few people not many of
them that work harder than Dave Ramsey
but and every one of those in every one
of those cases are doing if they're
doing something with their talents their
gifts their intellect their looks in the
marketplace they make more than I make
but I'm not bad I'm not mad at Beyonce
she's a much better dancer than I am and
I suspect most of y'all would rather
look at her on a screen than me and I
wouldn't blame you and she makes a lot
more than I make I'm not mad at Bill
Gates I'm not mad at Warren Buffett I'm
not mad at hope
they all got more and I got I'm kind of
I'm happy that they have succeeded and
every one of those by the way started
with nothing most of those I just
mentioned are billionaires if not multi
billionaires be careful of jealousy and
envy it says more about you than it does
the society it says more about you than
it does capitalism it says more about
you than it does a spiritual walk of
someone else be careful when you accuse
someone else of being extravagant
opulent or out of control with their
spending you take care of you that's a
full-time job
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 25 28
without self-control a man without
self-control is like a city broken into
and left without walls Harry Truman said
in reading the lives of great men I
found that the first victory they won
was over themselves self-discipline with
all of them came first there is no
discipline without self-discipline folks
that's the truth I have trouble saving I
have trouble losing weight I have
trouble dot dot dot
self-discipline self-control it's kind
of like you know I hear the Millennials
they say whether they call adulting yeah
adulting growing up one definition of
maturity is learning to delay pleasure
you pay a price to win it means you're
grown-up
whether you're 22 or 62 you pay a price
to win means you're grown-up
the first battle is self-control
personal finances 80% behavior it's only
20% of knowledge the problem with my
money is the guy I shave with if I can
get that guy to behave he can be skinny
and rich we know what to do we just
don't do it you listen to this show and
you know what to do you listen to show
to hear other people that know what to
do but aren't doing it or
other people that know what to do and
did it and they're inspiring how'd you
do that
self-control self-discipline you should
never say to someone you need Henry
cloud talks about that I love it
little Johnny you need to go clean up
your room little Johnny does not need to
go clean up his room or he would have
already done it but you need to create a
circumstance in which little Johnny
suddenly discovers I need to go clean up
my room otherwise mom's going to take
away my freaking life I'm going to be
grounded so I need to clean up my room
I'm going to flunk this test if I don't
study you need to study no I need a
study that's when you stay that's self
discipline not mom discipline you cannot
discipline be disciplined to four other
people you can put them in situations
where they wish they were but you cannot
be disciplined for other people they
have to grow up they have to decide you
have to decide I have to decide when you
decide that's when your life changes see
that's the powerful thing as God gave
you the right to choose you can choose
you don't like the way things are going
change just now you just changed ready
ready set go change you're not stuck
you're not stuck just change is it gonna
take a while
yeah is there gonna be some pain when
you change you bet but change change
well our family has always what you
gonna live in your family curse change
well we're hillbillies we're Cajuns
we're Italians we always do what and
then you put some negative thing after
that and you label your ethnic group or
your heritage with that let this
negative thing we've all got tempers so
stop change we don't know how to save
money so learn
change we don't know how to be nice to
our wives
so change you have the power it's a
power of choice the power of choice is
an amazing gift decide that's what we
admire when we watch these debt-free
screams or listen to these dead free
screams that's what we admire when we
run into our friend we ran into a friend
this week who had lost 38 pounds since
I've seen him only dude where'd it all
go I mean I was just like I'm so proud
of it proud of his success what'd you do
he has I just didn't eat as much well I
had gone insightful man Wow where'd you
come up with that formula and then you
say something stupid like I wish I could
do that yeah you could you just decide
it's change I like chocolate cookies I
know don't eat as many of them change I
don't like being broke change work more
spend less save more it's a hard formula
in it it's hard not because of the
formula not because the math is I don't
know if I can ever get out of debt I
don't understand math yeah you do you
understand math we're not dealing with
you know some graduate level calculus
formula here people this is the second
grade we're dealing with here you
learned addition and subtraction in the
second freaking grade you understand the
math don't tell me I'm good at math you
got out of the second grade okay that's
it it's not a chemistry formula here
it's the second grade
don't spend more than you have oh that's
insightful Ramsey you know I gotta tell
you it get you elected to Congress
because nobody up there has got that
figured out don't spend more than you
have and you will have money left over
to give and to save and you will prosper
when you give and you save because you
don't spend more than you have well you
don't know shut up don't spend more than
you have so make more but don't spend
more than you have this is how you
become a millionaire this is how you
change your family tree this is how you
change your destiny how you change your
life how you have options in your life
to drive a nice car instead of a piece
of crap this is how you get to go on
vacation on the good cruise ship instead
of the cheap one don't spend more than
you have don't spend more than you have
see the problem is is we've we all have
gotten so prosperous in America that
even stupid people are prosperous we're
so prosperous that even undisciplined
dolts are prosperous we're so prosperous
that poor people are prosperous compared
to other countries and other other
civilizations and so average is
prosperous below average is prosperous
in our culture average is $57,000 your
income that's average if you make
$34,000 you're in the top 1% of income
earners in the world you're a one
percenter wealth inequality whoo you
need to give some back because you make
$34,000 a year because of that we've
just gotten lazy and we've forgotten the
ancient word that will set you free you
have to learn the ancient word if you
want to be set free no one says that
anymore
because it's politically incorrect
you're not allowed to tell entitled
people this word everyone's entitled you
cannot use this word anymore you can't
use it for yourself and you cannot use
it on anyone else it's very very
unpopular I'll teach you how to say it
because it will cause you to build
wealth and it will change your life
are you ready you press your tongue
towards the roof of your mouth you make
a kissing motion with your lips and you
blow air past and release your tongue it
sounds like this no it's a word you're
not allowed to say anymore no it's a
complete sentence
daddy I want know we we we need a new
carton no you want dessert no no will
change your life but it's abrasive and
conflict based and visceral and it'll
freak your life out and people will get
mad at you no it's a wonderful word we
need to reinstate it in America no that
puts this our that I Ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there
is ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
folks is interesting to think about
here's the thing here's the thing that
goes through people's minds and it went
through my mind and went through
Sharon's mind when you're driving a
crappy car you live in a crappy house
while you're getting out of that you're
living like no one else so that later
you can live and give like no one else
it feels like you're the only one that's
driving a hoopty
you think when you're sitting at the
stoplight that everyone is staring at
your trashy car they're not there in
their own little narcissistic world
they're actually looking at their phone
checking Facebook to see who liked their
last post they're not looking at your
car
they're not looking at your car they
don't care about your car not nearly as
much as you care about it and not nearly
as much as you think they care about it
or your house and here's the thing it's
temporary
how many of you out there everybody
raise your hand have you driven a car
that was so bad that if you put tires on
it it doubled its value
oh you've driven a car is so bad that
you had to give it a name all blue the
Green Monster the The Swamp Thing I mean
yeah I babe the Blue Ox right I mean how
many had a car is so bad you had to give
it a name I've had I've done every bit
of that I drove a car so many people
don't know what this is I'm so redneck
here's what I did I drove a car for
several years and I never had any new
tires I bought retreads do any of you
even know what retreads are that's used
tires that they sorta put new treads
around but they would fly off sometimes
if they got hot and blow the tire so you
always had to have a good spare if
you're driving with retreads I went to
college on retreads yeah yeah so been
there done that
but the point is do that with a purpose
do that so you never have to do it again
drive like no one else so later you can
drive like no one else
maybe I'm Kang gay retreads now yeah
this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]
this is the show where we talk about
money in a way everyone can understand
it in a way that applies to everyone the
danger of these simple concepts is those
of you that view yourself as
intellectuals those of you that view
yourself as sophisticated sometimes you
look at something that's simple and you
don't understand how profound it is like
the borrower is slave to the lender oh
but I use credit cards to get my miles
you actually think you're going to take
on a multi-billion dollar company who
studies your behavior more than you
study your behavior and come out on the
right end of this stick that doesn't
make you sophisticated that makes you
blatantly stupid think about it did you
know the credit card is the most
aggressively marketed product in the
history of humankind
nothing has been sold to anyone in any
culture in any kind of a volume close to
the credit card no product line or
service has had anywhere near as much
money spent on marketing and
sophistication to sell it to you
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
is spent to sell you this product and
then you're so stupid that you think
you're going to get away with using it
for free if you do it's going to be a
short-term thing or if you think you do
you left out some of the variables
example when you spend using cash it
activates the pain centers of your brain
you have an ouchy moment when you hand
over uncle Benjamin Franklin dad gum I
just bought dinner when you Laye uncle
Benjamin Franklin in that black plastic
train
his coffin because he's going away and
he's not coming back you put him inside
that little visa or American Express
fold-over vinyl thing that the server
brings you and you lay uncle Benjamin
Franklin in there you have a moment with
Uncle Ben Uncle Bill I'll never see you
again you know this is happening when
you pay with plastic and I interview you
24 hours later you don't know what the
total was on the bill you can't tell me
what you spent you don't know what you
spent at the gas pump because you stuck
a card in it you pump the gas and you
walked away you can't tell me what your
gas bill was in the days that we used to
walk into the market and lay money down
on the counter and then they would give
you change because you didn't round it
off when you were putting your gas in we
knew exactly what we spent on gas in
those days today you don't even know
what your gas is you don't know I use a
debit card I can't tell you what mine
was can I tell you what it costs to fill
up my truck the other day I don't know I
didn't notice just stuck the card in put
the gas in drove away I'm just like you
cash activates the pain centers of the
brain there's two or three things that
activate memory memory is activated
primarily by pain fear heavy emotion of
some kind positive pleasurable emotion
will activate memory that's why you
smell something and you remember a girl
you dated in high school
smell activates that memory that's what
happens and so it's that that's the
process so here's the thing if you can't
remember it it means the pain centers of
your vain brain we're not activated and
when we do surveys with what you spent
on that meal as you walk out of the door
the restaurant you can't tell me what
the total was how around twenty five
dollars around fifty two dollars I don't
know fifty six fifty silver for that I
don't know I don't even remember I think
I left the tip
left the big tip because I've been
drinking you know now you really can't
remember anything right so this is how
people handle their money and yet you
tell me you're gonna beat the credit
card company you spend 12 to 18 percent
more on average when you use plastic
than when you use cash that's what all
the studies show us because you don't
feel the pain in the world's worst place
is the grocery store they are the best
marketers on the planet the best
merchandisers on the planet is a grocery
store man they know how to put the food
at the right place old-fashioned example
the easiest example is the bread and the
milks at the back right because
everybody walks into grocery stores
buying bread or milk and they have to go
through the full length of the store and
have every opportunity to impulse on
some kind of jar of peanut butter and
jelly mix together pre-mixed for you I
don't know what you're imposing on but
there's something getting your attention
it must be those new peach Cheerios I
heard about today and guess what all the
stuff is at the I level they get your
attention and they pay for the shelf
position as you walk to the back to get
your bread and milk and you can't walk
out without spending money it's that the
the the aisles are designed for you to
buy stuff and when you use plastic at
the grocery store you have no idea what
your grocery bill is and you spend more
he's been more on clothing
oh yeah throwing that accessory oh yeah
you'll pick up other people's tab at the
restaurant I'll buy you dinner tonight
nothing anything about just drop 50
bucks never think a thing about it now
I'm not saying you shouldn't be generous
I'm not sure saying you shouldn't
accessorize and I'm not saying you
shouldn't enjoy some purchases at the
grocery store I'm just saying you know
do it on purpose and if you think get
credit card use even if you're paying it
off every month cost you zero then you
are a very naive individual that has
been influenced by an industry that has
spent more to influence you than any
other industry in the history of the
world that should give you pause that
should give you pause if anybody else
was selling you that hard on anything
you would your shields would go up but
for some reason when it's credit cards
were like oh no damn I have this figured
out I'm 26 and I've got this figured out
I'm 26 years old I make $42,000 a year
but I'm gonna beat up on old Discover
Card they don't know anything I've got
them beat I'm getting those Discover
points not costing me a thing you know
how stupid that makes you saying when
you say stuff like that I'm making all
my money on my airline miles you know
I've met with thousands of millionaires
I've never met a millionaire I said Davy
no I made all my money on my airline
miles that my breakthrough was my
discovery points
I'll pay mine off every month Dave I'm
beating up on the credit card company
I'm getting the use of their money wink
wink millionaires just don't say stuff
like that now some of them use a credit
card they do pay it off every month but
I got to tell you their lifestyles are
so conservative
besides you know when I set them up next
to you middle-class people are spending
everything you make and trying to
convince me that I'm a troglodyte
because I don't use credit cards well
I'm not broke anymore this is a
multi-millionaire troglodyte you're
listening to why because I start
understanding that behavior affects your
ability to build wealth more than all
your little math tricks you think you
see all the variables on the borrower is
slave to the lender it doesn't say
except airline miles the borrower is
slave to the lender it doesn't say
except Discover points the borrower is
slave to the lender
it doesn't say except I got 0% interest
on my new car which lost $7,000 when I
drove it off the lot so it's not really
0% is it how stupid are we I mean you're
gonna you're gonna hand me a nickel in
front of me while you're picking $100
bill out of my back pocket and call me
smart think people think think if
someone's shoveling stuff down your
throat at this rate to the rate of
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
and their ability to sell and to market
to you is beyond any other
sophistication of any other marketing
program there must be money in
follow the money follow the money
so I don't have any credit cards I have
to debit cards you can do what you want
but it's working for me this is the day
for MC chef as we've been doing this
millionaire research one of the pieces
of data that we've discovered is by
studying 10,000 millionaires that the
average millionaire drives a 4-year old
car with 41,000 miles on it and of
course it's paid for and they haven't
had car payments in decades which is how
they became a millionaire because the
average car payment now is over five
hundred dollars about five hundred four
dollars a month over eighty four months
if you invest five hundred and four
dollars from age thirty to age 70 you'll
have somewhere around five million
dollars in your Roth IRA I hope you like
your car our advice
knowing that car is lose sixty to
seventy percent of their value in the
first four years is to buy a quality
used car unless you have a net worth in
excess of a million dollars then if you
want to buy a new car you can afford to
take the loss on it but the worst car
accidents do happen on the showroom
floor well Dave I'm always worried about
buying a used car well what are you
driving if you're driving a car that you
bought two months ago it's now a used
car if you buy a driving a car you
bought five years ago it's a used car
what are you driving
listen the vehicle quality is so high
now that we get through three hundred
thousand miles out of a car most of
these cars run and run and run and run
and run if you have take care of them so
don't buy a new car unless you've got a
net worth in excess of a million dollars
now how do you negotiate the best deal
on the car well the same way you do a
lot of things as a couple of keys to
negotiating one is he with the most
knowledge wins so study learn
about that car go on trader.com
go on Kelly Blue Book and edmunds.com
and look up stuff about the car google
the car read articles about the car look
at different versions of the car
different packages that are on the car
the luxury package the standard package
the two-door the four-door the different
engines that are in that particular car
learn all about a Honda Civic if you're
going to buy a Honda Civic learn people
impulse a big purchase like a car that
makes you stupid
you don't impulse that you study that
and then pay cash of course now most the
time paying cash means that you are
doing a bank transfer but sometimes you
can walk in with the cash and just lay
it on the table it's not that much money
I mean $7,000 $10,000 $15,000 whatever
it kind of blows a dealer of dealers
mind but certainly if you're buying from
an individual when you put cash on the
table it says we have a deal
it doesn't say oh I need to check with
my banker you ever sold a car on
Craigslist I need you can't quit my
banker and then you never hear from him
again I'll take it but I think my banker
I'll do it never hear from them again
when you like cash on the table there's
no I need you checking my banker in
there it's a done deal baby it's locked
in right and listen doc just don't get
married to one corner be prepared to
walk away listen when you bought
something emotionally even the most
inept seller recognizes the body
language changes I mean you guys know
when somebody's bought something right
even though they haven't done the deal
the negotiation is over once they know
you're married I'm married oh this car
so just be quiet let them talk the
seller that is tell them you know you've
looked this car up you've studied a lot
this seems a little high and then be
quiet let them talk you can negotiate
online there's a lot of ways you can do
it you can have the car inspected and a
good thing to do too is check with one
of our endorsed local providers on the
insurance
and find out what it costs to insure
that car you might be looking at one
$7,000 car that's almost twice as much
to insure as another $7,000 car you can
get a quote from one of them or on your
existing cars jump in there and get a
quote from the LP most people that get a
quote from our LPS because they're
brokers they shop among a bunch of
different people and they get the best
possible deal they save like 700 bucks
that's the average so and one in three
drivers 33% of you buy your insurance
and you don't shop your insurance before
you buy it that's just dumb it's an
expensive thing just like not shopping
the car before you buy that stuff don't
do that never done anything really
stupid with money if you have that makes
you over 12 almost all of us have my
wife Sharon and I started off with
nothing when we first got married most
people do I think and I start buying and
selling real estate and I got rich by
the time I was 26 I was a millionaire
making 250,000 a year but I'd done
stupid I borrowed too much money bank
got sold to another bank and some Guinan
of the city looked down so there's a kid
26 years old those as millions of
dollars let's limit this relationship
which is banker talk for ruin his life
they called our notes and we spent the
next two and a half years of our life
losing everything we owned we were sued
we were foreclosed on and finally we
were bankrupt I'd do everything
backwards I met God on the way up when I
was becoming wealthy most people meet
him at a point of crisis I met him on
the way up I got to know him on the way
down so twenty-eight years old with a
brand new baby a toddler and a marriage
hanging on by a thread we got the
opportunity to start from zero again
only I had to figure out how money works
not what your broke brother-in-law's
opinion is
how money really works and so as a
Christian I decided I would figure out
what the Bible has to say about money
and I talked to old rich people I didn't
want to talk to young rich people I've
been him I didn't want his opinion in
business we study successful people in a
certain area and then we emulate or copy
what they're doing in order to have the
same success they've had it's called
best practices that's why you hire a
personal trainer they have abs and you
have a keg they know something you don't
know they do something you don't do and
so we learn from someone that knows
something we don't know because they've
actually done it not have a theory about
it see I don't really care what your
theories are about money if you're broke
you're just arrogant and stupid you live
in your mother's basement you write a
Money blog and nobody cares what you
think
the rims he doesn't understand the power
of credit cards oh my god really after
30 years you're still writing that stuff
you've got to be kidding me
so we learned how to handle money and we
learned that money really is fairly
simple
it's just hard to do there's only about
four or five things you got to do to win
if live on less than you make you live
on a plan written budget you need to get
out of debt because when you don't have
any payments you have money your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income you've got to learn to save and
invest and you can't do that when you're
in debt don't have a plan and don't live
on less than you make you know why
people don't put money in their 401k and
the Roth IRA is because they're gonna be
money because it's all going out the
door and stupid but car payments and
Sallie Mae's got her own bedroom at your
house because she's lived there for so
long this is pretty simple stuff guys
it may be primitive
it may be easy to understand but it is
very hard to do because it has
everything to do with you changing your
heart and the way you function and the
way you live your life and you live like
no one else so that later you can live
and give like no one else because that's
the last one there's a high correlation
and all of our data between people who
win with money and those that are
generous generosity is a key element and
people who end up winning with money and
it's pretty simple it's because generous
people are attractive selfish people
aren't they're ugly attractive people
seem to get more opportunities in life
would you agree we all want to help
someone who's attractive I'm not talking
about physically attractive but they're
likable the person that holds the door
for you versus the one that customs you
for doing it only helps you pick up your
groceries when they're rolling around
the parking lot because the bottom fell
out of your bag that's a generous person
they might be a person gives you some
money because you're broke you don't
have money for food or you're going
through a hard time and they help you
out there's a high correlation between
generosity and financial success and
it's not that financial success allows
people to be generous it's the
generosity causes people to be people
that are lovable likeable more than
selfish people and they have a tendency
a prosper it's pretty easy formula
really if you think about it and when
you're out of debt the room she doesn't
understand the PO críticos out there
watch the power of credit cards destroy
people's lives for years I absolutely
understand the powerful credit card and
I watched stupid people write clickbait
articles about me and other people
saying how to use the credit card the
proper way to use a credit card and
credit cards are good for reward points
yeah I've never met a millionaire that
said Dave you know I made all my money
with airline miles they those Discover
points put me over the top that was my
breakthrough financial moment never met
a single millionaire and I've met with
thousands of millionaires never met one
that said that
we also I can't believe people's fault
fall for credit card debt I can't
believe people continue to use these
stupid credit cards it's like somebody
the half the population is dying on lung
cancer everybody standing on going well
I guess cigarettes kill yeah well no
kidding
unbelievable the credit card is the
cigarette of the financial world used to
be cool everybody thought it was neat
and people are catching on that it ain't
a good idea hello this is not rocket
science people live on less than you
make
Becky's on Twitter do you literally mean
beans and rice or is that an
exaggeration to make a point
Becky you've got to be kidding me do you
really think people doing this plant
only live on beans and rice I mean
really twits on Twitter really of course
not it means lower you're stupid but
lifestyle and quit spending money like
you're in Congress is what it means it
means quit going out to eat you're broke
it means quit buying the most expensive
thing at whole paycheck over there
and and start watching get your dadgum
coupons out and have a meal plan and
actually cook from scratch because it
saves money and don't go on vacation
you're broke and don't buy that you're
broke you have clothes in your closets
stay out of the mall live on less than
you make that's what it means if the
live on less than you make in order to
pay off debt in order to save and invest
in order to be generous you can't spend
more than you make and end up anywhere
but in bankruptcy court and people are
doing it every day everywhere see this
stuff we teach here folks is not hard to
understand it's very hard to actually go
and do it this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]
CNNMoney reporting Amazon didn't kill
Toys R Us here's what did it's true
online shopping didn't help matters but
the struggles of Toys R Us predate the
boom in online shopping many of its
wounds were self-inflicted the company's
biggest problem it was saddled with
billions of dollars in debt that debt
stopped it from making the necessary
investment in stores and that meant an
unpleasant shopping experience that
doomed the chain the company told
employees Wednesday that it would close
or sell its Us stores after 70 years in
business if you're going to have that
breadth of inventory you need someone in
the store to help you find it help you
experience it said Greg Patel lead
partner at retail consultant 80 Kearney
it's hard to sell toys in a cold
warehouse environment Toys R Us debt
problems date back to well before Amazon
was a major threat its debt was
downgraded to junk bond status in
January of oh five at a time when Amazon
sales were just four percent of the
current level much of the chains
resources were devoted to paying off
that massive debt load rather than
staying competitive Toys R Us filed for
bankruptcy in September 2017 it
disclosed it had about five billion in
debt and was spending about four hundred
million a year just to service that debt
I Heart Radio also filed chapter 11
bankruptcy last week on twenty billion
dollars and that a bunch of their radio
stations carry this show we're glad that
they're on the air and we're glad to be
on the air with them but it's the same
exact situation the debt there's nothing
wrong I Heart Radio the operations are
clean the app works the they're one of
the largest owner of radio stations in
America they do a good job they're good
operators they're not incompetent we
work with them all the time no problems
really other than twenty billion in debt
and it's just a hard to operate under
that
of yoke around your neck because see
here's what it does like here's what
happened with toys-r-us okay toys-r-us
started to realize that they needed to
have an online presence and become a
click and mortar Papa Dave that would be
me
actually bought grandkids stuff on Toys
R Us website but their website was
clunky there's high friction very hard
to operate very hard to navigate through
and you know given clunky most people
are gonna click old prime over at Amazon
right you don't want to clunky you want
to quick easy checkout right boom I'm
out of here and the problem is that same
stinking toy just about every times over
there on Amazon so you're not just
competing on toys you're competing on
the way your website operates the
marketplace moved and if you don't move
with the marketplace you get taken out
and so because they were so saddled in
debt they could not do the investments
in their website infrastructure that
they needed to in the robustness of
their website the elegance of their
website the ease of use for their
website if they had poured four hundred
million dollars a year into their
website because they didn't have that
five billion dollars in debt they had to
give that money to they'd still be here
as the problem wasn't that they didn't
have a good selection the problem wasn't
that they were bad people we've got a
Toys R Us right about a quarter of a
mile from this office where I'm sitting
right now and I have shopped in there
since our children were little its its
iconic it's a shame that that chain is
gone I mean it was a wonderful I had you
know I you know we our kids had friends
that worked in there in high school
we've bought kids stuff their grandkids
stuff their birthday party stuff they're
some of the first Ramsey kids shopping
experiences were in that particular
store just down the street here what
killed him
it was that they could not respond
to the disruption in the market the
disruption the market being something
like Amazon and the fact that people are
now doing more and more online ordering
and their online ordering sucked they
could not respond they knew they needed
to I think they do I didn't have any
discussions with their leadership team
but I I think they knew they needed to
they didn't have any money if they had
poured four hundred million dollars into
their infrastructure on their website I
think they'd still be here because I
think they were an iconic brand and
here's what's interesting when they were
rising when they when they were coming
up you know what people in small towns
were saying I don't see if you're not
old you don't know this but when old
people like me I remember we used to
have independent toy stores in virtually
every town just like you had an
independent hardware store before Home
Depot and Lowe's in virtually every town
and often times you had you know little
independent clothing stores that you
know Walmart let's come in and take it
out so what's happened is those little
independence got took out taken out
because they didn't adapt Toys R Us took
them out a decade ago I mean a
generation ago and so what happens in
business is 100% of time there's going
to be a disruption 100% of the time
there's going to be change and if you
are deeply in debt in your business just
like in your personal life you don't
have the ability to be nimble float like
a butterfly sting like a bee and go with
the change you can't move when the
market moves because you're paying a
stupid Bank because you stupidly signed
up for so much you can't breathe in debt
payments but if you can move when a
disruption comes along the disruption
can actually become the biggest blessing
to your business instead of a threat to
your business give you a great example
of that in the 1920s we used to have I
didn't I wasn't
but we Americans had little boxes in our
kitchen that were insulated boxes to
hold a big cube of ice called ice boxes
because there wasn't a refrigerator in
your kitchen yet and companies would
deliver those blocks of ice with big
tongs and those blocks of ice would keep
your food cool in your kitchen or you
used a cellar Frigidaire a division of
General Motors invented a thing called
freon and refrigeration was born
now everybody had refrigerators in there
in their living room in their kitchens
and they didn't need ice anymore you
know what the ice houses did a bunch of
them went out of business you know what
one of them in Texas did they started
selling eggs and bacon and other goodies
out of their store the store was called
7-eleven they adjusted to the disruption
this is the Dave Ramsey show a ratio is
on Twitter Dave is a car a bad
investment even if you have the lease
under a company well I
if you take thirty thousand dollars and
you turn it into ten thousand dollars a
thirty thousand dollar car loses value
down to ten thousand dollars you can't
hide that inside of a company you still
lost if you own the company or if you
didn't put it in the company you own the
car you still turn thirty thousand
dollars into ten thousand dollars
putting it in a company doesn't make the
thirty thousand dollars not turn into
ten thousand dollars it still turns into
$10,000 and a lease is just another way
of financing a vehicle you don't dodge
the loss in value with a lease you pay
for it in the lease think about it if
you leased a $30,000 car and you drive
off the lot with it and you pay payments
for three years and you turn the car
back in the car is worth $10,000
do you think the car company that you
lease that from is gonna lose that
$20,000 from that 30 down to ten
oh no they're not gonna lose that money
they charged you for that 20,000 inside
your lease payment dummy so I mean your
lease payment includes the loss of value
you're renting the car while you're
renting it it's going down in value and
so the included in your rent is the loss
in value the cost of capital called
interest and their profit it's all built
into the lease so you're giving them
profit you're giving them interest and
you're covering the loss in value while
you rent the car for the three years and
the includes the $20,000 in loss and so
the lease does not hide
you should lease depreciating assets
that's the dumbest but statement I've
ever heard in my life and these quote
financial people say that you're at
least depreciating assets no you
shouldn't
it's just financing depreciating assets
is all you're doing you're covering the
loss of value in that because the lease
companies are fairly good with math they
don't sign up to lose money on the stuff
they're leasing to you they're renting
you a copier they're renting you a car
they're renting you a cell phone
whatever it is and when you give it back
to them it's worth a lot less than when
you took it out of their store and you
cover the cost of the loss in value plus
profit plus interest thus comes your
payment so leasing a car is actually
when you back into the math the typical
car lease is somewhere around the
effective rate of about 14% interest
not counting profit and how can you do
that well you can use a financial
calculator okay it's fairly easy if you
you have the opening part of the lease
on a closed-end car lease is a fairly
simple equation you've got the equate
you've got all the numbers for the
variables for your math equation for
those of you know I run a financial
calculator
you got the what the car is what the the
MSRP is of the car at the time you take
it off the lot what's the sticker on the
car what's the car residual value
meaning what can you buy it for at the
end of the lease the difference in those
two is how big a loss they're taking on
it actually it's not even the MSRP be
more like their invoice minus their
holdbacks what's their real cost on the
car okay what's up what's the dealer's
real cost on the car the manufacturers
real cost on the car somewhere around
invoice minus residual value that's how
much it's going to lose in value during
the time you've got the lease out
they're not gonna let you buy it at the
end of the lease other than what they
think it's gonna be worth at that time
you take that figure that loss in value
and deduct that from the lease payments
and take out a profit margin I just make
up a profit margin number about 10% or
something they want to make on the sale
of the vehicle and the rest of that is
called cost of capital translation
that's interest and your cost of capital
when you put that into a financial
calculator during that period of time
will back out most of the time right
around thirteen to fourteen percent
interest consequently Smart Money
Magazine Consumer Reports and Dave
Ramsey's calculator I'll say leasing a
car is the most expensive way the most
expensive way the biggest ripoff in all
of automotive methods of all the
automotive methods all the ways you
could get at it so you can pay cash for
a car you can finance a car straight up
or you can lease a car what's the most
expensive way to drive a car of those
three the car lease they make more money
on leasing than they do on the sale of
the automobile that's how this works
folks they make more money on financing
than they do on the sale of the
automobile but they would rather release
it to you than anything because they
make more money on that the dealer when
they sell the
contract for the lease payments back to
their manufacturer the Lexus dealer
selling it back to Lexus Motor Credit
the Toyota dealer back to Toyota Motor
Credit the Ford dealer back to Ford
Motor Credit they make more on the sale
of the merchandise I mean on the sale of
the contract for the payments than they
do on the sale of the car so the car
lease is nicknamed around here the car
fleece because there's an old saying
that if you got ripped off you have been
fleeced like fleecing a sheep cutting
all his hair off leaving him bald you
took his hair you got fleeced you got
screwed that's what a car fleece is the
most expensive worst way to own a
vehicle cars go and you can't hide that
inside of a company a bad deal is a bad
deal inside of a company a bad deal is a
bad deal the math sucks on this stuff
now I'm not against you have a nice car
I'm just against your nice car having
you the average car payment in America
right now is 506 dollars over 84 months
that's according to the National Auto
Dealers Association so if you take 506
dollars and invest it from age 30 days
70 in a decent growth stock mutual fund
you'll have 5.6 million dollars I hope
you like the car so those car payments
are costing you car payments are the
mantra of the middle-class you guarantee
you will be broke your whole life as
long as you stay in car payments because
it's the most expensive thing that most
people buy that goes down in value the
most expensive thing most people buys a
home at least it goes up in value well
we go finance these cars and you're
sitting there with a thirty five
thousand dollar kid hauler with payments
coming out your ears that's six hundred
and forty two dollars a month so that
everybody's safe and has their own DVD
player in the back of the headrest but
they have no college fund
well that's just stupid you're driving
their college fund what a world we live
in where a minivan is now a status
symbol god help us seriously can you
believe what some of these minivans cost
have you looked at a Honda Odyssey I
mean you can get a really nice Mercedes
for what you can get Honda Odyssey for
something lievable yeah I mean think
people think think pay cash for your
vehicles if you want to be wealthy buy
vehicles the total up to be less than
half your annual income if you want to
be wealthy I don't want you to have a
junk car I'm now asking you drive a
thousand dollar beater the rest of your
life unless you make three thousand
dollars a year if you make three
thousand dollars a year we need to work
on your career you need to keep your
cars down and not fleece them and not
get worn out by these car manufacturers
the hair getting filthy rich on your
stupidity you're gonna stop and think
really thank you for joining us we're
glad you're here you know there's two
things when I talk about investing to
people that they say
they say well nobody can beat the market
I'm just gonna invest in index funds I
read a book and I read an article on the
internet you know everything on the
internet is true Abraham Lincoln said
that think about it it'll come to you
later the other is is that people say
well you can't beat the market and
investing is too complicated
I mean investing is intimidating
investment people are intimidating
I feel 2 inches tall when I talk about
investing it's intimidating well the
second one is true it is intimidating
but it shouldn't be it's really not that
complicated and when you sit down with
someone that actually knows what the
flip they're doing they can help you put
the cookies on the Shelf where you can
reach them
that's called a teacher and you don't
understand about mutual funds and you
understand about the track record on a
mutual fund and that's how I started
investing many years ago now I know
there's a lot of people that have
opinions about my investment advice but
I do have millions of millions of
dollars in mutual funds I wonder how
that got there it must have been that I
understood something about that that
money just didn't appear there I haven't
hit the lottery I was bankrupt at 28
years old
I'm 57 so what happened during that
30-year period of time well I used the
investment principles that I talked
about here on the air I don't tell you
to do something and then go do something
different I do what I tell you to do oh
and by the way it worked for me and lots
of others
lots of millionaires calling in on the
millionaire theme and say Dave I got out
of that I loaded up my 401k with the
four types of mutual funds I loaded up
my
fire away with the four types of mutual
funds and Here I am 20 years later and
I'm a millionaire thank you and I get
that all the time so apparently the
stuff we're teaching works and it's not
that complicated and my mutual fund
groupings have beat the market you just
pick mutual funds that have outperformed
the S&P it's really not rocket science
not all of them have outperformed the
S&P a lot of them haven't
over half happened but don't pick one
that didn't you would be better to do
that but I mean you know it's like some
of you sitting at a racetrack and you're
gonna bet on horses I don't bet on
horses just because I'm don't know
anything about it and I don't gamble
because I don't like losing money I work
too hard for it so but if you're sitting
I've went to a dog track one time or a
horse track one time when I was a
youngster and they tell you you know
this horse has not won a race ever
so bet on that one stupid you know this
horse won the last three races oh I
probably might bet on him you know
that's all you're doing when you're
picking a mutual fund did it beat the
market if it didn't beat the market then
don't pick that mutual fund that's not
rocket science that horse hadn't won a
race don't bet on that horse why is this
hard it's not hard and this idea that
you have to do what's called passive
investing and surrender and say oh well
you really can't beat the S&P Dave
Ramsey doesn't know what he's talking
about I don't know I mean I pulled up my
stop the other day and looked at unless
see anything I got it written down here
just because I don't have it all
memorized let's see here oh the mutual
funds I'm personally invested in the
four types I talked about over the last
40 years of average 13.4% you can't get
12% on your body I I know I got 13 okay
and the S&P during that time averaged
eleven point eight one percent which is
real close to twelve stupid people
thirty-year my investments have averaged
eleven point three this and peas
averaged ten point eight nine so
outperformed the S&P on the 30 on the 40
outperform the S&P on the 20 on the
10-year outperform the S&P huh go figure
so how did I do that
I pick four mutual funds that outperform
the SMB I pick horses that win the race
I mean what you look down to the track
record and it's got a little chart in
there it's got the S&P one line and if
your mutual fund you're looking at lines
not above this Soompi line on the chart
you're looking at the wrong one pick you
another one why would you bet on a horse
I don't want to race this is really not
rocket surgery people I mean think about
it it'll come to you Wow so how you do
this well you sit down with somebody
knows what they're doing and they teach
you about mutual funds and that's how we
came up with a whole smart Wester pro
idea we put that in place to help people
that don't have a lot of money and don't
know anything about it and are
intimidated but then along comes the
internet and lies to you and you can't
do that oh really
okay maybe you can't but I can and I
have and it's resulted in millions and
millions and millions of dollars
lots of millions by the way it's worked
out good
I'm having a good time yo life is good
so if you're ready to do this you want
to sit down with someone too he'll look
at your financial picture and help you
do your investing here at baby step four
you're ready to get started you want to
be a millionaire you want to live like
no one else so later you can live and
give like no one else so you can retire
with dignity and not have to buy that
cookbook 72 ways to prepare Alpo and
love it you know people that rich hire
wealthy it wasn't an accident they
didn't get to wealth you get to
retirement go how that happened where
did that come from
they're not surprised they know exactly
where that money came from it was an
intentional act
year after year month after month
paycheck after paycheck being deducted
into their 401k into the Roth IRA into
good mutual funds year after year after
year after year after year after year
it's just not sexy it's not a fish story
to tell on the golf course it's just the
tortoise hee
just keeps walking haze ugly just keeps
walking he's ugly and nobody notices him
but that's how you become a millionaire
what all the data points tell us so the
other Dave Ramsey comm click on smart
investor I'm not in the investing
business I'll give a rip if you invest
or not I'm here to teach you but I am
getting a little spit sick and tired of
the trolls out there bumping around the
internet talking about how stupid Dave
Ramsey's investment advice is when my
net worth is tens of millions of dollars
so I must be doing something right other
than just selling books yeah I sold a
lot of books that's where some of that
came from for sure but most of it came
from investing you guys in real estate
that I paid cash for and in good mutual
funds see if you put money in at the
bottom of the market when the market was
what sixty nine hundred sixty four
hundred whatever was at the bottom but
for the crash the big crash of 2008 you
remember when the world came to an end
if you put money in there and what's the
Dow today twenty-four thousand what is
six thousand to twenty four thousand is
that four times you think you guys that
are quick with your second grade math is
that four times so if you put in a
million dollars at the bottom what would
you have now four million dollars uh
this is not hard but the stock market
you see you've got to learn people
you've got to learn what's really going
on out there in the real estate world
and in the investing world if you want
to have any money the CD is not going to
get you there it's a certificate of
depression it's paying less than 1% in
most cases
if you got a really good one it's one
and a half zippy
so click smart Wester at Dave Ramsey
comm put in your information it'll drop
down a list of the smart mister pros the
people we recommend in your area they'll
sit down with the heart of a teacher and
calmly show you mutual funds that I'll
perform the market and they'll
uncomplicated ly complicated process
where you understand it and when you
understand it that only then do you do
you're investing don't do it because I
said so only then this is the Dave
Ramsey chef well on every one of my
social media feeds for the last five
days or four days since this article hit
people have been exploding their brains
are frying out of their heads over this
article in The Wall Street Journal Mike
Maru has 1 million dollars in student
loans how did this happen Mike Marui a
37 year old orthodontist made a big
investment in his education and as of
Thursday he owed 1 million sixty
thousand nine hundred and forty five
dollars in student loans mr. Murrow pays
only fifteen hundred and eighty nine
dollars a month not enough to even cover
the interest so his debt seven years
from seven years at the University of
Southern California grows up by a
hundred and thirty dollars a day in two
decades his loan balance will be two
million dollars he and his wife Melissa
have become numb to the burden focused
instead on raising their two daughters
if you thought about it every single day
miss Marie said you'd have a mental
breakdown due to escalating tuition and
easy credit the u.s. now has 101 people
who owe at least a million dollars in
federal student loan debt five years ago
is 14 people while the typical student
borrower owes 17,000 and that's not true
it's 37 the number of those who owe at
least one hundred thousand has risen to
two and a half million the government
essentially allows graduate students to
borrow any amount to cover tuition and
living costs with few guardrails on how
the final sum will be repaid
these are choices we are not coercing as
says the Dean of us C's Herman Ostrow
School of Dentistry where mr. Monroe
went to school this is one of the most
expensive dental schools in the u.s. you
know exactly what you're getting into
says the Dean dental school is the cost
list of higher education programs in the
US an average of seventy one thousand
eight hundred twenty dollars a year
the USC program now costs 91 thousand
dollars a year and a hundred and thirty
seven thousand when living expenses are
included halfway through dental school
he said he started to worry about the
soaring cost of his education why did it
take halfway you're in the most
expensive dental school in the u.s. I'm
sitting here saying holy crap should I
really be doing this mr. Murrow called
should I drop out miss Meru 35 said her
husband and her decided it was too late
to turn back if he quit her transferred
to a cheaper school he still owed for
the loans he already had yeah so the
cheaper school would keep you from doing
what the USC education helped mr. Murrow
earn 225 thousand last year no being a
dentist helped him earn twenty five
thousand that you're working for a
corporate practice and Draper Utah
outside Salt Lake City that compares
with 158,000 median income for dentists
some dental school educators fear that
the eye-popping let me help you all the
site for a second that's a miss that's a
misnomer they stopped just for a second
um the median income for dentists is one
hundred fifty eight thousand but not for
orthodontists and he's northa dontist so
let's learn the difference here it's 225
he's not making extra money because he
went to USC where he went to school did
not increase his income he went to the
most expensive school he makes an
average income note to those of you who
want to go to expensive school because
you say it's going to cause you to make
more money
it doesn't anyway moving on some dental
school educators fear that the
eye-popping costs to enter the
profession could this way good prospects
from even trying yeah think dental
schools financial aid director estimated
that the basic four-year program would
require four to five hundred thousand
dollars in student loan debt mr. maroon
his wife concluded dental school is a
good investment we're like well we can
make this work
yeah they'd sense to me they took it out
on a lower interest rate long story
short the interest rate went up they got
themselves in trouble a law passed in
Congress in 2001 severed the link that
tethered student loan interest rates to
Treasury rates and the rates went up
causing him to get into a bigger mess
the one luxury I'm skipping along was
buying a used Mercedes Benz which
carries a payment of a three hundred
ninety dollars
the couple then bought a home using a
four hundred thousand dollar mortgage
mr. malroux took out her name she used
an inheritance from her grandfather for
the down payment and her mother
co-signed to the loan because she's
married to a broke dentist
mr. Marui then entered into a
government-sponsored repayment program
on the loan for after 10 years as loan
will be forgiven but when you add up
everything he's paid in he will have
paid back a million dollars even by then
and then you and I will eat the other
million roughly since refinancing his
debt with the federal government in 2015
mr. mr. Murray's balance has grown by
one hundred fifty thousand dollars it
will keep growing through the 25 year Oh
its 25-year life of the repayment plan
until it reaches 2 million the sum will
be forgiven and at current tax rates
will cost him another seven hundred
thousand dollars in income tax for
forgiveness of debt the government
repayment plan affords the Murray family
a comfortable life their home is on a
mountain with panoramic views of the
snow-capped peaks surrounding Salt Lake
City they take vacations including a
recent trip to Havana and they drive a
used Tesla yeah it doesn't make your
head explode extreme things like this
always do make the news and obviously
this is an extreme thing but what it
does point out is a whole bunch of
things one thing it points out is is
that you and I are stupid America we're
stupid because we elected a congress
that allows a student loan program like
that to be in place because you and I
are getting ready to pay this guy's bill
these are federally insured student
loans the taxpayer insures the student
loans no one else gives unlimited lines
of credit to 18 year olds on unsecured
debt except you and me
no banker in his right mind would give
this and bankers loan money like hot
potatoes they'll loan money to a dog
that's dead
and they won't loan money to you but now
you and me we're so bright we think the
students you know college education is
so important and the whole economy would
collapse in America would be a bunch of
illiterates if we don't step up and pay
these if we don't step up and insure
these student loans so I'm telling you
you need to call your Congressman based
on this article right here which wakes
you up and say the federally insured
student loan thing needs to stop you
want to stop colleges from overcharging
it's real simple when nobody goes there
because they're too freaking expensive
their rates will drop but when they have
an unlimited supply of money from the
government insured by stupid people like
you and me and signed up for stupid
people like this guy who didn't even add
up what his costs were gonna be until
he's halfway through this is a whole
group of stupid people in a pile stupid
college is overcharging stupid taxpayers
that are willing to sign up willing to
sign on for this guy cuz you and I are
gonna pay this your tax money is paying
this guy's bill because we're stupid
because only stupid people alone people
like this money so we're stupid we
guaranteed this loan it's a federally
insured student loan the student loan
program is a freaking disaster Mike
murrow's life is a disaster so Mike
you're in Salt Lake City my man you're
in a hurt you're in a world of hurt you
become the laughingstock of America
after this article I'm so sorry people
are probably writing him hate mail like
crazy I'm not gonna write your hate mail
I'm not gonna pile on I've done dumb
things too if you're within the sound of
my voice and in Salt Lake City I promise
you you are you get in touch with us we
will help you for free you will not like
dr. Dave's prescription for your life
you're getting ready to sell everything
my man and work like a maniac but I can
actually get you out of this mess I'm
probably the only one that can you get
in touch with me and I'll help you this
is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]